我在婚姻里遇到一些事情，
希望能听听您的建议，
我先说一下我的情况啊，
我我今年是35岁，
我跟我老公在一起十年了，
然后我们结婚七年，
有一个六岁的小孩，
然后我们开了一个夫妻店，
年收入大概是20多个，
就是不是特别稳定，
但是这几年是这样子，
然后小孩呢，
是我们两个自己带的，
就是我是前两天发现他在网上就是那个第我现在知道的是他一共是已经输掉15个了，
哦，
我理了一下，
有3个是他平时他自己说花销掉的，
然后有12个是输掉的，
有11个是他家里人给的，
因为我跟他家里人关系很不好，
我们已经好几年不联系了，
我也不去到他们家了，
所以他们也没有跟我讲，
就是他们都知道这个情况，
但是我是不知道的，
就是相当于瞒着我一个人嘛，
我现在不知道怎么办嘛，
因为我现在想的是这样子，
我先跟他分手，
我先做一个法律上的切割，
但是我不能放弃他，
因为我感觉如果我不管他的话，
他可能就真的没办法救了，
这样子我知道你的。
这个心啊，
可能是比较善良，
但是换句话说，
你管他，
你就能救得了他吗？
因为我家里是10年之前出事的嘛，
然后他也一直陪着我，
也没有嫌弃我，
我现在也只有他一个亲我了，
除了我小孩之外，
然后我就想我们在一起10年了，
我跟他也分不开，
所以我想我现在就这么做，
往后的路要怎么走，
就是往后的路，
第一可以先领一个那个证儿，
对，
你俩协商着，
先领证儿写明白，
嗯，
没有夫妻共同的债务，
各自名下的债务归各自来偿还，
呃，
把现有的这个财产分清楚，
把孩子的抚养权分清楚，
然后孩子的抚养费写清楚，
他每个月该给孩子多少抚养费写明白，
这是第一，
第二的话，
以后你自己挣的钱，
你不要心软，
不要给他还债，
他如果欠债的话，
他上黑名单，
就让他在黑名单待着，
他如果说被各种催债的话，
你千万不要心软，
替他还债，
你就要让他上黑名单，
要让他借不着钱，
要让他没有信用，
他就不能捅更大的窟窿。
他越是在黑名单上呆着，
越是就贷不着款，
办不了信用卡，
他没有办法借更多的钱，
他就没有办法产生更大的窟窿，
你要是说你心疼他，
你可以对吧，
我给你一口饭吃，
我让你有地方住，
就是说你打死都不能替他还账，
贷款我帮他还过两次了，
我说我想想事不过三，
这一次我是不能走了，
其实我知道你想的都对，
我没有人可以商量，
所以我可能就是能够希望有一个人鼓励我一下吧，
他有父母吧，
他爸爸是已经去世了，
然后他妈妈也是线下，
你知道的也是做这一个事情做了一辈子了，
然后对我又非常不好，
所以我就不跟他们来往了。
你需要人生需要负责的，
第一是你自己，
你需要对自己负责任，
第二是你生的孩子，
你需要对你生的孩子负责任，
我，
我说句实在话啊，
就你挣的这个钱够养活你，
够养活你的孩子就够呛了，
你哪里来的自信，
你还能拯救另外一个男人，
你哪里来的自信你能拯救这个人？
其实我也希望我的事情能够给别人一点，
那个吧，
因为他，
我跟他就是裸婚的，
我就是恋爱了，
我就。
当时就觉得他家不管他，
我心疼他，
结果我就把自己搭上了，
然后我们买房，
他们家也没有注意，
本钱都是我自己，
然后我们也是裸婚的，
我们婚礼也没有办，
我也没有礼清，
就这么早了10年，
然后我老公是他，
他挺好的，
他对小孩子也好，
然后他买菜烧饭就是他好的，
他不好的就是他没有挣钱能力，
就是在我们这店不是一起的，
他主要是我在弄，
他就帮我打打下手，
这样子那我想本来嘛，
一辈子可能也就这样子了，
我也能过下去，
嗯，
多挣一点，
少挣一点，
但是嗯，
他现在摊上这个了，
我感觉不行，
我如果我再这样子下去的话，
我可能就要我跟小孩就要被他拖死了。
对你有这个想法，
有这个觉悟，
这个思考的问题的方向是对路子的，
我知道这个是非常，
你就记住一句啊，
就记住一句，
无论他怎么求你怎么跪，
怎么威胁，
怎么怎么样，
你都不能再替他还债了，
你挣的钱只够你和你的孩子吃饭，
只够你和你孩子生存下去了。
对你充其量说我给你领完了那个证之后，
我煮饭的时候我多煮一碗，
我炒菜的时候我多放点菜，
我充其量我能对你做到的就是这仁至义尽了，
你要再想让我去替你还债的话，
你等于是让我和我的孩子一起去陪你去陪葬，
对我也是这么说的，
我说我再给你一次机会，
就是说我们虽然说去领这个证，
但是我们不分开，
我们还是一家人，
我会监督你，
只要你不要再犯三五年，
你我给你三五年的时间，
如果你不再犯，
我们还是有机会的，
嗯，
就这黄我这个路子，
我我的想法是这样子的，
嗯，
然后还有一个问题，
就是这样子，
我是现在就去领呢，
还是说半年以后在现在，
现在现在因为涉及到孩子读书的一个问题，
半年以后我不知道会发生。
什么事情，
孩子读书，
因为你一样，
如果不是夫妻，
孩子读不成书吗？
哦，
不是因为我们，
我是为了我小孩读书买了一个房子，
然后是爸爸的户口迁过来的，
如果说爸爸和孩子的户口在这个房子里，
如果读书的话是于防护一致，
然后如果我跟他分了的话，
就相当于可能是第二类了，
我问了一下，
基本也能读上，
但是如果不分的话，
是百分之百可以给他读上，
这样子办那个证儿和迁户口这事儿不是必须同步，
就是他户口还可以在那个房子里，
他给他的名字也可以还在那个房子里，
但是你可以去约定，
他占1%，
你占99%，
我不想跟他约定，
因为这个钱本身也都是我出的，
我就先去跟他领证吧。
嗯，
而且一点还有一个问题了，
肯这是就是涉及到我自己关于小孩的，
因为我本来是想着我是在二一年买的房，
然后这个房呢，
就相当于花完了我所有的积蓄，
然后现在如果卖掉的话，
就相当于我只能还掉所有的债务，
然后我的债务还有110万，
然后我们也没有存款，
然后我自己还有一点装修的贷款，
是我自己在负责的，
没关系的，
然后我现在有两条路子，
就是我卖房，
我就。
嗯，
没有任何债务了，
然后我带着孩子去生活，
然后孩子读书的话，
只能读一个就不怎么好，
我也不知道他能不能得到说去哪里读书，
因为我没有地方可以去了，
然后还有一个路子，
就是我坚持下去，
那我就要承担我小孩以及我每个月的房贷支出，
就所有的债务，
就相当于我以后一定要一个人带小孩了，
那现在卖房有损失吗？
损失的话，
卖房的话就是我房子也没有了，
钱也没有了，
小孩也读不上书了，
坚持的话每个月还多少？
坚持的话我现在攒了一下，
一年大概5万多吧，
那你大概一年能挣多少呢？
这几年保守估计应该20来个吧，
那你可以的呀，
那你可以坚持下来的呀，
如果我我努力坚持下来的话是可以的，
但是因为我们干的是电商嘛，
我感觉也可能不是特别稳定，
这样子能坚持啊，
你跟孩子有一个稳定的居住的地方啊，
咬咬牙，
我也是这样想的，
你我我现在心里有着落一点了，
不然不然的话我就还是觉得我自己到底是对的还是错的，
我就不知道，
就是堡护孩子和堡护自己的过程当中，
不要有什么道德压力，
不要有什么怎么怎么地了。
好好，
谢谢你这意思啊啊，
他会坚持他拜拜，
因为我琢磨一下，
我觉得他他根本就不叫伤害他自找的，
同意吗？
因为是他那个男的自找的，
根本就不伤害了那个男的，
所以她在堡护自己和保护孩子这件事情上的话，
她就应该更加决绝，
更加果断，
更加有底气才对，
你别到时候拒绝她的时候就觉得哎呀她哭的那么伤心，
哎呀，
他都给我跪下了，
这么多年的情分，
你在保护你和保护孩子这条路上，
你需要拒绝的那种道德压力啊，
就是会越来越大。